live tv means you can't plan for what's
about to happen and sometimes there are
some serious medical surprises let's
watch it together
it looks like reuben is in the lead and
here i'll wipe out
that could be a knee injury an ankle
injury and a head injury and a broken
rib all in one riverside park robleth
global news great sign off the fall was
so bad it reminds me of johnny
knoxville's thing with the
[Applause]
bull costume contest we do it every year
so it was a lot of fun let's get started
our first caress
oh
oh the show cut to black and went to an
extra long commercial break but when it
did come back on wendy was back up
that was not a stunt i'm overheated in
my costume and i did pass out but you
know what i'm a champ and i'm back get
evaluated overheating is a real issue
dehydrating is a real issue heat stroke
is a real issue and it shouldn't be oh i
just had a heat stroke i fainted i'm
good to go now that's not how it works
okay a little dancing a little dancing
my dance moves are just as good as this
yeah
what can go wrong medically here
[Music]
you okay
[Applause]
usually when patients describe a knee
snapping they mean the knee gave out
most commonly this can happen with a
meniscus or an acl sometimes a pcl
injury if there's some kind of like
weird collision that happened
so
oh
i see what happened okay so there's
potential for a meniscus injury there as
well as an mcl injury at that moment if
you have a tear of that ligament you're
just gonna get so much swelling and
bruising he's gonna get an x-ray to make
sure that no bones are broken he's gonna
get some crutches he's gonna get
follow-up get an mri find out that the
medial meniscus and the mcl are torn
potentially either do rehab and or
surgery and we'll be back on his feet
dancing his little heart away
[Music]
the problem is
oh
i did not expect a face-first plummet
like that
call for help first thing that we do
call for help before even investigating
and the microphone's still in her hair
the first thing you want to know is
making sure that the person is conscious
are they breathing do they have a pulse
remember if there's no pulse you call
9-1-1 and you start those chest
compressions chest compressions chest
compressions but it looks like she's
kind of with it so my prediction here
and suspicion is that she had something
known as a vasovagal singapore episode
where because of nerves because of
extreme tension her blood vessels
dilated her heart rate dropped and as a
result she wasn't bringing enough
circulation to her brain and she
collapsed this is very dangerous not
because of the actual situation that's
happening with the low blood pressure
but the fall the fall is a dangerous
part like she fell face first
as an emt you're really in a bad spot
because you have no idea what just
happened the person isn't talking you're
trying to get information you don't know
does this person have underlying medical
conditions so for their role the most
important thing is stabilizing the
patient getting them to an area where
they can receive adequate care
[Music]
she was treated for dehydration released
from the hospital she returned for the
show stop around okay so dehydration can
precipitate a vasovagal episode but it
could also cause a fainting episode all
on its own because what happens is if
you're dehydrated meaning you haven't
consumed enough beverages you don't have
water content you actually lose a little
bit of blood volume and when that
happens you can't generate enough
pressure to bring the oxygenated blood
to where it needs to go like the brain
and the vital organs especially when
you're standing and as a result with
this blood pressure drop you actually
just faint as a life-saving mechanism
your brain wants you to go flat because
when you're flat the lower blood
pressure can still circulate the
oxygenated blood throughout your body
correcting dehydration in a severely
dehydrated individual is also very
important and needs to be done carefully
because if you rehydrate too quickly
with the incorrect type of fluids you
can actually cause swelling in the brain
and cause the patient to die that way
there's a lot of things that need to be
taken into account here
oh she looks stressed
[Music]
is she okay
[Music]
again very difficult to figure out
what's going on i like this position it
makes it easier for the blood to return
back to the heart and go up to the brain
the kayla has a condition that's
pretty rare
in seventh grade i was diagnosed with
vasovagal syncope that is not a rare
condition now maybe in individuals who
it happens to quite often is a rare
condition there's two mechanisms at play
during this type of syncope one is
increased parasympathetic nerve output
meaning that we're increasing that rest
digest mechanism nervous system in your
body that opens up blood vessels which
is good when you're lying down and
relaxed not good when you're trying to
perform physically on stage because it
drops your blood pressure therefore not
bringing oxygenated blood to the brain
and then at the same time it shuts down
sympathetic nerve firing so think about
this the blood vessels in your legs
expand so blood pressure drops now if
your heart was allowed to
sympathetically respond it would
increase its cardiac output by beating
faster as a result you'd be okay you
wouldn't even feel that something's
going on but because you're shutting
down the sympathetic and over driving
the parasympathetic you're creating a
really bad disimbalance that causes
someone to faint and potentially really
hurt themselves well a very very heavy
heavy divertation tonight we had a very
dare garrison
by let's go to terrorist terrorism to
the bit they had the pet do we know what
happened here look at a potential stroke
she claims it was a migraine there are
types of migraines that could present
with neurologic symptoms known as
complex migraines i would want a full
workup to see if there was in fact a
stroke now in young otherwise healthy
people sometimes the cause of a stroke
can happen as a result of a pfo that
generally people don't know about that
they have but as a result if you ever
have a blood clot in your leg and it
starts traveling to your heart it can
transfer instead of going into your
lungs into the left side of your heart
through that hole and as a result gets
shot up to the brain leading to a stroke
this is me 10 years ago dan harris i've
read this book where he talks about this
very moment researchers report people
who take cholesterol-lowering drugs
called statins for at least five years
may also lower their risk for cancer but
it's too early to prescribe statins
slowly for cancer production at this
point i realize i'm helpless so i bail
right in the middle
uh that does back to you we're gonna go
back now to robin and charlie i knew
with rock solid certainty that i had
just had a panic attack on national
television panic attacks are a real
phenomenon and people think that they're
all in their heads panic attacks may
start in the mind but they continue out
to the rest of your body which means
that you feel like your heart is racing
a million miles an hour you can't take a
deep breath there's an impending feeling
of doom you feel weak you feel numbness
tingling that's why so many people will
describe it as a near heart attack
episode and sometimes we do want to rule
out a heart attack it's been years in
war zones where i covered the heroics of
our men and women overseas and got a
real taste of both the horror
and the adrenaline of combat after years
of always barreling forward when i
finally slowed down it was as if my mind
revolted and i got depressed and so in
my free time i briefly but stupidly
began self-medicating and it was those
recreational drugs my doctor would later
tell me that almost certainly produced
the on-air panic attack i wouldn't say
it's necessarily those drugs that cause
it they could have indirectly caused it
by increasing the feelings of anxiety
because a lot of people will take
feel-good drugs when they're depressed
and as a result those feel-good drugs
will mess with your neurotransmitters
leading to higher highs but also lower
lows and as a result withdrawal symptoms
that can make it feel like you're having
a panic attack or make it feel much
worse so much so that it could disrupt
you in your place of work i do recommend
you read dan harris as 10 happier check
it out on audible my partner
stuff went wrong during my own live
event my tour my alive tour click here
to check out everything that went wrong
as always stay happy and healthy
and sorry for the hair
[Music]